Welcome back. We are joined today by
Jang Shu Shin uh to discuss the
developments uh between the United
States and uh Iran. Uh so thank you very
much for coming back on.
>> Thanks.
>> So I I
well the first thing I think about is in
regards to this war is that the Iranian
targets all seem to be very well
calculated in terms of economics. And I
think this is interesting because
usually in all American wars they
there's some economic interests to go to
war but now we see them um well not just
shutting down the straight of moose but
you see them when they essentially
forced the Americans to spend their
expensive uh interceptive missiles. All
of this has seems to have an economic
underpinning but the really big thing
appears to be the possible attack now on
the petro dollar. I was wondering how do
you see how do you see the vulnerability
of the petro dollar in this war?
>> Right. So I would argue that right now
this war in Iran it's primarily about
maintaining the petro dollar because
these past 10 years the world has become
increasingly concerned about the
viability of the petro dollar. Um right
now the United States is $39 trillion in
debt. Um the United States uh right
after the Russians um invaded Ukraine
froze over $200 billion dollars in
Russian assets which makes the world
question the legitimacy as well as the
credibility of the US financial system
because if the Americans can weaponize
the dollar against the Russians they can
weaponize US dollar against everyone. So
after that you saw this massive exodus
from US treasuries
um and right now China is establishing
the um gold corridor. Um so brakes is
trying to create alternatives to the
petrod dollar but for the Americans the
petro dollar is the very basis of their
empire and quite honestly it's the very
uh it's it's the objective of their
empire. Um so the United States right
now is going to fight tooth and nail to
protect the petro dollar. What this
basically means is to use its naval
supremacy, its control over strategic
choke points uh maritime choke points to
control trade access and basically force
nations to depend on US resources. So we
saw that United States um in January um
attacked Venezuela and now it's attacked
Iran. Um recently uh these past few days
there was a Ukrainian drone strike on uh
Russia's main export uh hub which
basically took off 40% of Russian oil
from the global market. And so Europe
and East Asia are now forced to depend
on the United States, North America for
energy. Um, and right now we're seeing a
uh pivot uh uh from Europe and East Asia
over to North America. And so that's a
strategy in place where uh the United
States basically wants to take take off
uh Russian um GC oil and force the world
to buy from the United States which
protects the petro dollar. But what we
know from history is that this sort of
hubris will lead to um a backlash and it
will lead to the world unifying against
uh the America eventually because quite
honestly America used to be the
policeman of the world and that's become
the pirate of the world and so uh maybe
in the short term you will see the
strategy working out but definitely in
the long term you will see the world
becoming much more aggravated by this um
piracy.
So what do they need to achieve then uh
in in this war? Because uh well I was
wondering if you were surprised that uh
the Americans appear to have walked away
from the negotiations at least that's
what it seemed like in uh Islamabad. Uh
do do you is is this to continue the war
then or is it simply because they can't
well the petro dollar won't survive if
the straight over moose is with Iranians
or what is the thinking here?
>> Right. So we've seen a very strange
sequence of events these past six weeks.
Uh the war has been going on for about
six weeks and we've seen a lot of
strange event events. So the moment that
the Americans attacked Tran and killed
uh their supreme leader, the Iranians uh
basically closed off the shumoose. And
in response, what the Americans did,
which was very surprising, is they
basically removed sanctions on both
Russian and Iranian oil, allowing the
Russians and Iranians to um make a lot
of money selling the oil. So that was
sort of surprising. And Scott Bezen, the
the Treasury Secretary, explained that
this is to maintain global stability. um
he's afraid that um oil will reach $200
and this would destabilize the global
economy. And as this war progressed um
we saw the United States escalate to
attacking civilian infrastructure like
universities
um bridges and railways. In fact,
there's real concern that the Americans
and Israelis plan to um choke and
strangle Tran to death, meaning cutting
off the railway system, the roads, uh
which would um put Tran under siege.
They couldn't get food and water from
the other parts of Iran. And Tran, a
city of 10 million people, would be in a
lot of trouble if that that were the
case. So, what we were seeing was
constant escalation. Then last week uh
we were on the brink because Trump
basically declared that if Iran did not
open the shoo then the Americans would
bomb Iran back to the stone age and Iran
obviously would would retaliate by
destroying GCC energy infrastructure and
the dissellation plants. So last Tuesday
we were really on the brink and it
seemed as though um we were heading
towards war three. Uh but then Trump did
something completely surprising which is
he basically uh offered an unconditional
surrender. Iran had a 10-point plan
which included uh that Iran would be
allowed to enrich uranium. It also
included that all economic sanctions
against Iran would be lifted. Iran would
be given sovereignty over the Hummus and
all security guarantees would be applied
to both Iran and its proxies, the Hu,
Hezbollah, Hamas. So these were the um
10 points um that Iran demanded and
Americans um Donald Trump basically said
that this is a workable framework and so
they agreed to meet in Sabbad to discuss
these 10 points um and use them as a
framework for a possible long-term
ceasefire. We know that once they reach
um Isabad uh JD Vance uh Jared Kushner
and Cricov basically blew off the
Iranians. They were not serious about
negotiations. Um the Americans went in
uh with some goodwill um hoping to reach
an agreement and that and that's where
the Iranians went, but the Americans
just just basically said no, we're we're
going to stick to our original demands.
And so the negotiations went nowhere.
And so now we're back um to where we
were uh a week ago. So the big question
then is why would the Americans do this?
What what's the point of this ceasefire?
And so um we can only speculate here.
Okay. So, so, so let me try to figure
out how Donald Trump thinks because he's
a businessman. And what does he want?
Well, his main objective is to maintain
American imperial supremacy u by
maintaining the petro dollar. And that
basically means forcing China and Japan
and South Korea um and Europe to buy
energy using the US dollar. That's what
the petro dollar literally means. And so
maybe the point of this war was to
destroy the GCC and Iran's capacity to
deliver oil to the world market and
force the world to rely on North
America, Canada, Mexico, and the United
States. Okay? So let's just say that is
the main objective. And obviously Trump
can't announce this because this would
piss off the entire world and you have
the entire world against the United
States. Well, in order for him to pull
this off, he would basically need to
gauge China's reaction because we know
that China and Iran are very strong
allies. China has invested a great deal
in Iranian infrastructure as part of the
Bel and Road initiative and China buys a
lot of oil from Iran. In fact, China
buys about 90% of all Iranian oil. Um,
so basically Trump needs to figure out
what can I pull this off and would China
agree to buy oil from me? Okay, so he's
a negotiator. He's his businessman. He's
practical. He's trying to figure out
what the um pressure points on China
are. And I would make the argument that
this u Iran Iran agreeing to this is
some of negotiations would not have been
possible if China did not apply pressure
on Iran. Okay. I would make this
argument because the Iranians have been
negotiating with Americans these past
few months and they know that the
Americans use these negotiations as a
pretext in order to um assassinate
leaders in order to um do surprise
attacks. So the Iranians know the
Americans have absolutely no credibility
at all. The Americans are not serious at
all about peace negotiations.
And these past few weeks, the Iranians
have been adamant saying, "You start
this war. Um, we're just protecting our
sovereignty and there's some important
negotiations. Let's just fight this to
the better end." I think that was the
right approach. This is what you this is
the attitude you must take against
bullies. So why is it that um the
Iranians suddenly had a change of heart
and says fine, let's negotiate in
Islamabad. In fact, they set a pretty
they sent a pretty high level delegation
to Islamabad, including the foreign
minister um to partake in these
negotiations knowing that Israel has a
history of assassinating uh negotiation
teams. Okay. So, they put their
diplomats at tremendous risk and I think
the only explanation is that right now
the Chinese economy is under a lot of
strain. China receives about 60% of its
oil and energy from the Middle East
including Qatar and Saudi Arabia. um
with China receives about a third of its
energy needs from Venezuela, Russia and
Iran combined and China's been very
lucky in that these three places have
been sanctioned. So China was has been
able to receive these these the oil at a
very deep discount uh which has really
helped the Chinese uh economy and now um
and now a lot of this energy is being is
moving offline. So the Chinese economy
is a lot under a lot of stress. So
Trump's trying to figure out, can I when
I go to China in midMay, can I propose
to Beijing, hey man, let's have a grand
alliance where you start to buy energy
from North America. And he's trying to
figure that out. And given that Iran
agreed to negotiations, I think that
he's figured out that the answer is yes.
China must agree because of the state of
the economy. And this is why we saw
right after the negotiations were
cancelled, Trump announced a naval
blockade against Iran because he knows
that right now China's a lot of strain
and he can bring China into um into an
agreement and and thus protect the petro
dollar. So So that's my explanation for
what's going on. I could be wrong. It's
all speculation, but I think this is
what makes the most sense so far.
the naval blockade. This is a well a
strange um conception because
it's it's unclear how it's going to be
upheld because they're not naturally in
the straight either. They will be far
away. So it's essentially the blockade
is would it entail attacking
Chinese ships entering? I mean it seems
uh absurd. What if they would um the
Iranians open up for Indian ships? Are
they going to start attacking Indian
ships? it it doesn't really make that
much sense. How how do you see this?
What what is uh how would this uh
blockade actually function or is it just
meant to choke off the the Iranian
ships?
Right. So from a practical perspective,
it's actually very hard to implement
because if you go close to the Iranian
coastline to Hamus, then you're in range
of Iranian ballistic missiles. And so um
the Americans won't risk that because we
we've seen that their aircraft carriers
including the Gerald Ford neighbor and
Lincoln have intentionally stayed away
far away from um Iran's ballistic
missile range. So they're afraid of
ballistic missiles and they know that
these ballistic missiles can sink their
aircraft carriers which will be sorry
which will be a tremendous tremendous uh
defeat uh strategically for the
Americans. So I think this is a pretext
to choke off the straight of Malaa.
Right. So there are two major choke
points uh for East Asia to receive oil
from the um Middle East. The straight of
Humus is what Iran controls. And so
response, America plans to choke off the
straight of um Mala, which is right now
basically controlled by Indonesia and
Malaysia, both of which are uh American
military allies. And um these these
nations have been heavily infiltrated by
the CIA. So I think that's the grand
strategy to basically use a straight
malaka to choke off East Asia from um
from GCC energy.
>> Yeah. But if the Americans actually go
through with this uh attempt to blockade
the the Iranians would probably respond
with their ally in Yemen, that is to
close off the Red Sea at uh Bab
al-Mandab. So, I'm just it it seems that
this could be well, it just seems like
this plan is weak at many levels. But it
kind of begs the question of how what do
you see being the likely success of the
United States achieving its objective uh
not just with the blockade but also with
uh preserving the petro dollar because
Iran is quite resilient and uh I'm
assuming that the Chinese uh you know
much like with the war against Russia
that they they know that they could be
next on the chopping block or that they
at least are the ultimate targets.
>> Right? So what America's mostly
interested in is trying to sustain its
debt. Right now America has $39 trillion
in debt. That's not that's not that's
that's not a problem as long as nations
continue to buy US treasuries. And we've
seen these past few years a movement
away from US Treasury and more and more
towards gold. Um the Chinese especially
are moving towards um gold. So how do
you force East Asia and Europe to
continue to buy US treasuries? Well, if
you are the own supplier of energy of
oil and gas, LG, they have absolutely no
choice but to sell their gold and buy US
treasuries in order to sustain their
economies. Right. So, yes, you're
absolutely right in that the Iranians
have um counter measures. The Iranians
could use the Houthies to close off the
Red Sea. Uh they could attack um the
pipeline that connects Saudi Arabia to
uh the Red Sea. There's many many uh
measures that the Iranians can do, but
the influence of the Iranians is
contained to the Middle East. Remember,
the ultimate objective is to knock off
Middle East oil and energy from the
market. And um that is very easy to do
as long as as long as you continue to
provoke this war. Now, I think the next
step is a ground invasion in order to
force Iranians to attack um GCC energy
and dalination plants. Right? So the
entire goal is to destroy the Middle
East which will force the world to pivot
to North America. So in a long in in a
short term this strategy will work out
because there's absolutely no
alternative uh for the world to um the
Middle East energy but in the long term
this will create a great deal of
animosity um towards the United States
which will ultimately destroy their
empire.
Well, Romano Prod, the former prime
minister of Italy and also yeah, former
president of the European Commission, he
he said something interesting along
those lines. He was making the point
that uh well, at some point the
Europeans will have to start uh getting
energy again from the Russians if they
want to thrive. But he also made a
prediction that the energy would open
once the Americans would begin to
control the energy infrastructure
between Russia and Europe. So
essentially the Americans taking over
Nordstream. Uh this is when the energy
will start flowing again. Uh which is um
uh well an assumption I guess that uh
that that that Americans want to be in
control over the energy architecture
otherwise they will not permit it. Um
but but but beyond this you know what
what Trump might be planning a common
argument is often that Trump is not
necessarily fully in control that he's
uh all uh if not compromised at least
under great influence from various
interests be it the neocons or the
Israelis how do you see this the extent
of uh Trump's control because um well
given how different his second
administration is compared to the first
one often gets the impression that it
doesn't always matter who you know sits
on the throne in the US.
>> I think in the first administration
there was a lot of concern um within the
deep state and the neocons and um the
different political factions within
Washington DC about Trump's um capacity
to be a leader because he was outrageous
in his speech and his rhetoric. Uh the
Europeans very much concerned about
Trump. Trump started this trade war with
China that was hurting the global
economy um and it was hurting American
consumers. Uh Trump did not seem like a
viable leader and he did not seem as
though he could maintain the uh empire
and people felt that if he stayed in
office longer the Europeans would drift
away. Um China would drift away. The
entire world would drift would drift
would drift away and American generally
would would die. But then what happened
of course was that Biden came to power
and Biden was essentially comeomaos. He
did nothing for four years. So Putin uh
invaded Ukraine and Americans didn't
really have a forceful response. I mean
they did do a lot of things like blow up
the North Pipeline. They sanctioned uh
Russian energy. They removed Russia from
the um Swift system. They s they um
froze $20 billion in Russian assets.
They did a lot of things, but none of
these things were actually uh useful.
And the Empire decided that regardless
of what we feel about Trump, um he is
forceful. He will act whereas Biden and
the Democrats may not act because
essentially they're a bunch of
And so the decision was made to um
reinstate Trump in 2024. And that's why
we are here today. So Trump is an agent
of empire. He is doing what the empire
requires. Okay. And so what what
happened before um during the unipolar
moment basically from 1999 up to today
was that America had a lot of goodwill
and um it was able to achieve the
consent of the world mainly by co-opting
the global elite. Right? So um all these
elites in Europe, in Russia, in China,
they're remaining concerned about um
engaging as much corruption as possible
so they can um basically transfer their
illotten uh gains into America. And this
doesn't work really well for the elite
for a long long time. But obviously
these nation states were not were not
very happy with the state affairs.
That's why you saw the rise of Putin in
Russia and the rise of sea in China
because there was a lot of concern among
the nationalists that uh America was
hauling out these these countries and
they were completely right in the
matter. So so now you're seeing a a
direct challenge to America empire and
so the only challenge is you don't have
the consent of these nation states then
you must use force to um enforce your
empire um w within these nation states.
And so before the uh American military
was used in order to guarantee peace in
the past american Americana it was used
to guarantee international trade. They
were the policemen of the world in order
to maintain the rules based national
order. And now that's and now that
Russia and China and other nations are
questioning the legitimacy of the rules
based national order. What Trump is
doing is he is transforming the
military, the American military from a
police force into a pirate force in
order to extract tolls from uh the
world. So we are in this situation
because Trump's first strategy was to
use tariffs
um on the world, right? To force
Europeans to pay tariffs to the American
empire. But the Supreme Supreme Court
struck that down because they said that
the executive branch does not have the
authority to um enforce tariffs. Only
Congress does. So Trump's like, "Well,
you know what? If Cong if you won't let
me enforce tariffs, then I'll just
enforce tolls. Okay? I'll make the world
pay tolls in order to have trade around
the world." And and that's why we're
seeing um um the Americans deploy one of
their navy into the Caribbean to block
trade into the Western Hemisphere.
That's why we're seeing this war in Iran
to block off um the world from uh Middle
East energy. And that's why we're seeing
right now the the US Navy uh basically
boarding uh Russian shadow fleet
tankers. basically stealing Shadow Fleet
tankers and and we'll see more of this
as uh the months go by.
>> Yeah. What's interesting with Trump
though, there's some consistency here. I
mean, many people I guess mistook his
rhetoric for being um you know, all
about peace. But if you listen to what
he said all the way going back to the
1980s, he was essentially scolding uh
all the Japanese and others for uh for
you know, taking advantage of the US the
way he saw it. So he he didn't say that
we shouldn't have a big empire. He just
said the empire uh they should pay us
for the privilege of being protected. So
it's not that he didn't want an empire.
It seemed he just wanted a better return
on investment. That is you know you have
to monetize the empire some otherwise
the the empire will kill off the
republic. So in other words it should
feed it. It looks as this is where he's
um his main differences. But that means
not just extracting from adversaries but
uh also allies. Um but uh I don't think
it's limited to Trump. I think overall
the United States will tilt more and
more in this direction because as they
have as you said exhausted themselves
with $39 trillion in the hole. Uh this
it's not as if you can vote for a
Democrat and suddenly they go back to
paying for the security of allies
anymore and having generous trade
agreements. that there's no going back
after you know exhausted to this extent.
Sorry.
>> Yeah. So this is a really important
point that you make. Okay. So remember
in 2016 when Trump first came out of
office he was saying the same things uh
you're saying which is everyone say take
advantage of us especially China. So
let's impose tariffs and make sure that
um that it's America first that America
is winning in this um in this trade
relationship. But after Trump left
office, Biden came in with the Democrats
and they institutionalized
his policies. Okay? So then the first
Trump administration, a lot of it was
personal uh especially his tariff war
against China and then Biden the
Democrats made it institutional. And so
we can the same um process here where
maybe Trump leaves office in 2028, the
Republicans lose, the Democrats come
into office and they won't change
anything. All they're going to do is
institutionalize it and make it a
long-term sustainable policy because
this is what benefits the American
empire.
So how will the great powers respond
then? Because the US obviously shifting
strategy. It's becoming more extractive
and more aggressive. Again, it's not uh
going well, it's not going down without
a fight. How do you see the the Chinese
and the Russians uh uh well reacting to
this? you mentioned before the China's
is gold corridor in terms of shifting
more to yeah gold instead of uh being
reliant on the US dollar but uh what is
seeing the overall all strategy here
because my impression is at least from
the Russians that they uh the
interpretation that Trump was someone
they could uh make peace with and uh you
know reset relation it appears to be
backsliding. I think they were quite
appalled by what has happened to Iran,
not just the attack on economic
infrastructure but also the you know the
killing of its leaders and it seems um
yeah very much to go against their
interest and also Trump never actually
did what he promised which was to end
the war in Ukraine. In all fairness this
could have been done if he would have
cut off uh you know the intelligence
agencies still working there.
>> All right. So again, I think we give too
much credit to Trump. I think that this
is a natural response
um of empire to its decline. Um we
historically empires have never have
never gone quietly into the night. They
have flailed against uh the wind and
they have tried to destroy the world as
they decline. And so we can see much
more hubris. We will see much more thugy
and piracy from America with or without
Trump. And so I think we are in a
situation um because of the limitations
of Chinese strategic thinking. So um
when China built the built and road
initiative which was proper with which
was a good strategy of trying to secure
uh resource independence from the United
States the problem was that when these
Chinese ships went to collect
commodities from overseas they were es
escorted by the US Navy. When they came
back they were escorted by the US Navy.
It was the US Navy that guaranteed the
protection of Chinese trade. And it
never occurred to Chinese policy makers
that one day, one of these days, America
could be like, why don't you steal the
cargo? You know, why are we escorting
these Chinese ships around the world?
Why don't you steal it? And so, it never
really occurred to Chinese policymakers
all this possibility. And I don't know
why why this is the case, but um we we
can go into many possibilities, but the
re the reality is that China is now in a
lot of trouble where China has invested
$200 billion
into the Middle East in infrastructure.
China right now imports 50 to 50 to 60%
of its oil needs from the Middle East.
Now that the sh of moves um has been
closed off now that this war is raging
in the Middle East, China is in a lot of
trouble. And again again this is all has
to do with the limitations of Chinese
strategic thinking. And so now China is
in a lot of trouble and in the short
term China has absolutely no choice
absolutely no choice at all but to agree
to Trump's demands which is that China
will become uh a major purchaser of
America American LNG. China has
absolutely no choice in the matter.
Okay. Absolutely no choice. There's no
there's China China can do know in the
mid and long term what's going to happen
is that Russia will start to challenge
America in the seas. It's going to
challenge America, American maritime
naval supremacy. Basically, what what
Russia is going to do is it's going to
arm it shuttle fleet. And there's no way
that that Russia could defeat um America
militarily uh in the seas. But America
will be forced to fight a war of
attrition. And over time, the American
Navy will be downgraded. It will be
degraded. and it'll be very hard for the
American um Navy to replenish its lost
ships. And so that's what what we're
seeing in the long term. But in in the
short term, there's actually nothing
Russia and China can can do.
Yeah. I often think about the current
situation. It resembles a little bit
like before World War I. That is you saw
Germany building and becoming stronger
and stronger uh in terms of industrial
production. Yeah. Steel production
essentially all the key measurements.
Meanwhile, the British control the seas.
The entire their ability to actually
compete against the British was uh uh
you know was in the hand of the hands of
the British. So all they had to do is
begin to cut off or threaten their
supply lines which is why the Germans
also had to find you know uh other other
possible corridors either land or sea.
uh but it's a little bit with the
Chinese I feel they have all this well
probably one of the motivations behind
the belt and road initiative that is you
can't rival the US as the economic
leading economy while the Americans are
then organizing their or
organizing their supply lines and their
their physical transportation corridors
it doesn't make much sense uh but this
return to
uh I guess uh well piracy as you say or
choking off these different
transportation corridors We've seen, of
course, the blockade on Venezuela, Cuba,
the hijacking of these Russian ships. By
the way, the hijacking of Iranian
tankers have happened for some years now
before uh this war as well. Uh so so I I
get it that hegeimon in decline will
begin to weaponize all the economic
levers of power that access to its
technologies and industries,
transportation corridors, banks,
currencies, all of this is weaponized.
Uh but the United States isn't all
powerful either. I mean how what is the
main challenge for the US to hold out
because as you said they're struggling
with their own debt. This is uh all
their economic trouble is also
translating into social and political
instability. So it looks as if you know
they can't afford to play this game with
the Iranians for too long. Uh that you
know at some point they will have to put
an end to this thing.
Um, I think like the goal is to have
this war continue for as long as
possible. And the reason why is that if
there were peace in the Middle East,
what would happen is that Russia, Iran,
and China would get together and form a
trade alliance to counter America's
control over the seas. And this trade
alliance could extend easily into
Europe, into Africa. This is what what
McKenna calls a heartland thesis, right?
where America and Britain um the way for
them to maintain their empire is by
controlling uh maritime navigation and
the great concern is that a power would
emerge in Eurasia to unite the heartland
and basically uh negate uh
Anglo-American naval power and so this
war in Iran cannot stop. If it stops
then Russia could achieve its north
south uh trade corridor and China could
implement its belt and road uh
initiative and given the uh how America
is starting to behave then I think that
Europe um the Middle East Africa would
happily join this trade alliance and
basically um try to try to ignore the
western hemisphere and Britain and so
there's no way that Brit that America
will seed Iran uh and and leave Iran
alone. it's going to send in ground
troops to create as much chaos as
possible um and try to disrupt the bel
road initiative. So what we're seeing is
that the Israelis and Americans are
targeting railways uh in Iran which is
crucial to the belt and road initiative
and so we can we will we can expect um
maybe more than the lawn of bel uh
infrastructure uh for years and years.
Yeah, I couldn't help but to notice the
targeting of the railroads as well as
well as some ports in the Caspian. So
this entire international north south
transportation corridor from uh which
have been building from Russia, Iran to
India, this is being uh undermined but
also of course uh Iran's connectivity
with with China. So, um, but, uh, but
I'm just wondering about the physibility
here because,
uh, how what exactly can boots on the
ground achieve, but also can the United
States get the boots on the ground
because they're quite, uh, overextended
already,
>> right? So, um, the boots on on the
ground, it's basically to maintain the
war, right? So the problem with um with
aerero warfare, which is what the
Americans and Israel have been using for
the past six weeks, is that um your your
it's going to be very hard to maintain
your your air power. Uh we're already
seeing some planes crashing because
they're not wellmaintained. We're seeing
the Iranians adapt very uh creatively um
and resiliently to American air power.
So you you can only establish aerial
supremacy by having boots on the ground.
And so I think the main objective of of
the boots on the ground is not
necessarily to take over Iran. I mean
that's a suicide mission, but it's
basically to secure the coastline and
try to degrade Iran's um air defenses
and basically force um Iran on the
defensive. The main objective I think if
if if I'm fighting this war I think my
main objective is to choke off tan
basically to cut off all railways cut
off all roads and basically force the
population into starvation.
>> So this is where you think we're going?
Uh
>> I think so.
>> Destroying the population or as Trump
would say kill off a civilization.
>> That's right. That that that would be
the strategy moving forward. Yes. to to
basically besiege Tran.
>> Just such a big country, it seems hard
to
Yeah. Again, if the railroads are
undermined, um but uh it also has his
domestic problems though, the that Trump
needs to, you know, it's not a popular
war among the public and he has some
fierce political opposition only
intensified with the political
polarization. Uh I I I did want to ask
about NATO though because this is uh was
often perplexing to many Europeans
because uh while you know in the Gulf
States they're now discussing the extent
to which uh the you know being frontline
states for the US is actually harmful to
the security. Uh they're having some of
these talks in East Asia as well. But in
Europe I mean they must be the most
loyal obedient
allies or frontline states of the United
States. Uh I I'm I'm convinced they
would have possibly joined the war on
Iran if he would have asked them before
it went south. But um but but why why is
does it seem to be such an objective for
Trump to I guess uh undermine NATO
because this is the main I mean the
Europeans don't have much political
imagination to have security without the
United States. So, you know, it looks
like a massive resource to have the
Europeans essentially buy whatever
America wants uh to to use, you know,
use their currency, buy their energy,
buy their expensive weapons. I mean, the
Europeans will do anything if they
believe America will be there for them.
So, why make this big show out of we're
not going to be there for you anymore?
Cuz if this one thing that would make
the Europeans break off uh and seek an
independent path from the United States,
it's essentially the US has to shut the
door on them because they're not
otherwise they wouldn't shut the door on
America. So, it's a bit strange how I
can understand that NATO's not um that
the Europeans, they're not really a
force amplifier. They're not bringing
much to the table. They're a bit of a
cost, but still, it's a bit yeah,
strange how dismissive he is of them,
though.
>> So, I think that the real war is
actually not between United States and
Iran. I mean, the real war is between
the globalists and the nationalists,
right? Right. So in the United States,
it it'd be a war between uh the
financial elite uh as as rep represented
by the city of London and Wall Street
versus maggot America first. And so what
Trump wants to do is basically
transition America from an empire into
something called a technate. Um which is
the idea of a greater North America,
right? So move away from the world and
just focus on consolidating uh greater
North America, taking over Canada,
taking over Greenland, taking over
Mexico, taking over Cuba, um Venezuela,
Colombia,
uh Honduras, Nicawaga. Okay. So, so
these countries that Trump has been
pissing off for the past few months.
Okay. But the grand vision is to
transition America into greater than
North America and become a continental
fortress that sells resources to the
rest of the world because the rest of
the world is at war and in and is in
desperate need of both fertilizer and
energy. And so um Trump really sees NATO
as part of the deep state as part of the
global globalist class. And so he's
using this war as a pretext to sever
relations with NATO. Basically, Trump
would be perfectly happy if NATO were to
go into Ukraine and be absolutely
massacred by the Russians. That would
solve um a major headache of of his. So,
um yes, there is this war going on
between United States and Iran, but we
have we have to forget that there's but
we should not forget that there's also a
shadow war going on between um the
globalists and the nationalists in uh
America. This is also why Washington DC
is supportive of Trump's war because the
globalists want Iran to be humble. They
want Iran to be destroyed so that they
can extend the hegemony of the empire.
They think that Trump is a useful idiot,
a puppet in uh in order to achieve this
goal. And that's why the Democrats have
not stopped him. You know there was
recently two weeks ago no kings protest
United States millions of people and
like you you you were allowed to say no
kings but you were not allowed to say no
war right you would think like that
people would be much more governized by
an anti-war settlement than it is than
they are are by like an anti-tyrant
settlement but during the protests which
were organized by uh democratic lobbyist
lobby groups uh which were very uh pro-
Zionist
you you are not allowed to voice any
anti-war settlement. So it just goes to
show you that all of Washington DC is
fully behind this war and they think
that Trump will be the scapegoat that
that even if this war goes badly, Trump
will be the one that takes all the
blame. the Republicans will will be
wiped out in the midterms and then uh
Democrats can uh steamroll back in
office in 2028 and then they can
implement a globalist agenda and destroy
MAGA once and for all.
>> Yeah, this language though the
globalists versus the nationalists. It's
fascinating that uh the first time I
read about this divide was uh by Samuel
Huntington none other back in 2004. He
wrote this article dead souls where he
was making the point that uh all this
globalization had essentially created a
a political elite detached from the
nation. So he was making the prediction
uh that the future divisions in the
world would be between the cosmopolitans
or globalist versus the nationalists or
patriots. So, uh, I thought it was
insightful. Again, it's, uh, 2004. Yeah,
it's been 22 years. And if you listen
to, uh, a lot of the new populist
leaders we have, this is what they're,
yeah, Marin Le Pen to De, this is
essentially the same language they also
use. Now, uh, let me just ask a last
question though. How does Russia fit
into this? because all the pieces kind
of make sense. The I understand the
rivalry between the United States,
China, uh the the problem of Iran, but
uh but Russia is, you know, it's an
energy superpower in many ways. It's not
doesn't have to be an opponent of the
United States. Uh it's within this
rivalry between the cosmopolitans and
the
and the nationalists, it's it belongs to
the the latter, it seems. So uh how do
you see this yeah impacting the thinking
in the United States but is a close
partner to Iran and China should have
had
>> right yeah so right now um United States
main adversary is not China um it's
really Russia because Russia is the only
country that has the resources
uh biblical will um and the ter
territorial integrity in order to
challenge American hijgemony
And so um right now America's major
concern is is Russia and this war
against Iran is really seen as a way to
counter uh Russia's aggression in
Ukraine. Basically once Russia went to
Ukraine um America has actually no
choice but to um attack Iran in order to
counter uh Russia's um possible control
over the heartland. And so this is going
to be the defining struggle for the
world for next 20 years. Not between the
United States and China but between
Russia and America. And the great
question is where will the world align
over the next um 20 years? If history is
a guide, most countries will start to
line with Russia because if you go back
go back to the Pelisional War, the main
aggressor was Athens. And what happened
ultimately was that um the entire world
ultimately aligned against Athens
because Athens was seen as the great
aggressor. So right now uh the great
aggressor is America and we can see that
the world especially Europe um and Iran
and China turning to Russia as the great
salvation and um what Russia will do is
start to challenge America in the seas.
Again I don't think there's any hope
that Russia will win against America and
the seas. Uh but Russia has absolutely
no choice but to start to challenge
America.